joining us now Republican congressman
Sean Duffy and congressman Chris Stewart
who have both reviewed the memo it's
great to see both of you gentlemen -
Laura boy you guys have to work now for
a living you're working Friday nights
just like I am I mean you guys go home
on the weekends everyone's in town so
we're probably working tomorrow and
Sunday till you get to go home we do our
baby I'm gonna get my violin out for you
seanix you've cut enough wood in
Wisconsin this season anyway you know to
cut anymore let's talk about what you
saw in this number I know you can't
discuss it it's classified
however 140 of your fellow members have
seen it only one Democrat does that
surprise you that Democrats have such a
stunning lack of curiosity about its
contents Laura I'm going to jump in on
this if could not only have I seen the
mammal but as a member of the Intel
committee I've been aware and have been
helpful in creating this memo and to
answer your question let's back up a
little bit if we could for the last more
than a year we heard one thing collusion
Cluj inclusion and then we didn't and
and then we heard obstruction
obstruction and then we didn't and the
reason being is there was no evidence
for that but this is what we do know the
second story now we know that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC hired fusion GPS
that hired a foreign agent who used
foreign assets including more likely
Russians and created the dossier that we
know is garbage and the question now is
did the FBI use that too before the FISA
courts were they honest in how it was
presented and did the FISA judges
exercise of prudence they needed in
questioning this material that's the
focus of this memo
the bottom line is this doesn't fit the
Democrat narrative that Donald Trump
colluded with Russia and so if it
doesn't fit the narrative they don't
want to see it because they're not
they're not looking to find the truth
they're looking for a pathway to destroy
Donald Trump and listen I don't think I
don't think it's helpful for Republicans
to froth at the mouth with what's in
this document I was deeply disturbed
I think there's serious issues at the
top of the DOJ and the FBI which is
laurel wider why they didn't want to
give this information to us it took us
four months and threat of
a congressional action to force them to
give us the documentation once I've
looked at it I know why they didn't want
to give it to us but and also the I
gotta Ted there's also and we've heard
someone may be prosecuted I would agree
with that claim but again America wants
hear the truth we don't want the
Democrat narrative we want the truth and
that's how a movement to expose the memo
is gaining steam and I think frankly the
Intelligence Committee will have a vote
they will release it Donald Trump will
clap his hands and say let's expose what
what the Obama administration was doing
with a video Jay an FBI remember
remember Barack Obama back and I think
it was the fall of 2016 I believe he
basically he like poo pooed the idea of
any politicization of the Intel
community working against Donald Trump
he you know he said that I can guarantee
you that didn't happen similar things
said by Susan Rice and other members of
the National Security Council that would
have had access or requested access to
the unmasking of individuals who had
been surveilled under the FISA warrant
that was a you know that was filed and
and granted so they they're they're
saying this is a Republican pipe dream
that you guys you know you guys just
don't want to answer the real questions
about what happened in this uh you know
with any dealings with the with with
Trump and Russia they just deny it deny
deny it
that's just silliness this investigation
has been going on for more than a year I
was in Moscow just before the election
and I came home and said a hundred times
they're going to mess with our election
it was clear that that was their
intention with this committee this
investigation has asked every question
we've interviewed dozens and dozens of
witnesses thousands of hours but the
facts are just the facts and if the
bottom line is if you've made these
accusations and at the end of the day
there's no evidence you have to consider
the alternative maybe these people are
innocent and by the way they weren't
accused of stealing bubblegum they were
accused of treason and to be fair to
them and to be fair the process you have
to be willing to say maybe the
accusations we've made aren't true but
then now what we're looking at
you have to be honest as well as say
these are incredibly troubling
revelations and by the way it's not just
FBI and DOJ there's information
regarding the political ization of the
CIA that to me is at least doubling the
American people know that as well
well you know the in both of you know
this very well but there were a lot of
warnings about what was going to happen
if Trump was elected going back to
August of 2016 there was a big piece I
remember I think it was a National
Review I just I just tweeted it out for
people to read that they were setting
him up at the time and there was this
was a former Intel officer worked for 25
years in the Intel community wrote this
piece and it was basically a warning
that people who say Intel is never
politicized they haven't been around
haven't seen they haven't seen recent
history over the past like 50 years or
so so that's one thing I want to I want
to play for you to both of you an
interview that Catherine Harridge of Fox
did it's not getting enough attention
frankly with Natalia Vail it's kaya who
is that Russian lawyer who was at that
now infamous meeting at Trump Tower that
got so much publicity and she asked a
question about you know what was the
meeting life what was the purpose of the
meeting let's watch y-yes 3/8 symbol my
meeting was not tied at all with Hillary
Clinton or anyone involved with any
Democrats could I just get the
Democratic bloc insists that I was some
kind of an Asian of the Kremlin I did
not collude with Russia the president's
son-in-law barely attended according to
her account on posting that show he came
after the start of the meeting and left
before it ended so we didn't even look
each other in the eye apparently she has
not been called to testify I get
questions from the mother team yet and
congressman Duffy you know look you know
you don't know whether to believe or not
believer and I was just trying to see if
I could understand the Russian in that
little clip and I pretty well pretty
much could understand it but tell us
what you thought about that why first I
don't speak Russian maybe you do Lorelai
I listened to it and I would say that's
exonerating the Donald Trump campaign
saying listen I had nothing to do with
Hillary Clinton and when I wasn't trying
to put undue pressure I was talking
about a basically a different issue yeah
that's right and and but if Democrats
hear this they'll say oh my goodness
this is further collusion between Donald
Trump and the Ross
they're trying to give Donald Trump an
escape hatch by sending her out and
saying there was no collusion here it's
just the way they'll they'll read every
different piece of evidence can I just
make one of the points we give
incredible powers to the FBI in the DOJ
and we want them to keep us safe
especially after 9/11 and and we're okay
giving that power as long as they use it
in certain guardrails and they respect
people's Fourth Amendment rights but
when they step outside the bound the
boundaries with which we set up for them
and they use it for nefarious purposes
that's when the American people get
riled up and that's why it's so
important that the memo come out the
only way we're gonna change the way the
FBI and the DOJ works is when the
American people know what they're doing
and so then partisanship isn't there but
the American people have the truth the
facts and can say we have to change this
and congressman's doing congressman
Duffy we just learned that the
procedural vote in the Senate failed so
it failed to avoid the government
shutdown that's where we are thus far
that way every indication was that
that's the direction it was going in but
we have definitive word that indeed that
procedural motion has failed meaning
will at least have a temporary shutdown
of the US government non-essential
employees will not be paid at least for
the time being they usually are paid
afterward so we'll keep track of that
for all of you one thing I want to do
for you congressman Stewart is have you
listened to something that congressman
Adam Schiff said earlier today oh it's
actually a full screen excuse me he said
this about your all of your comments
about this memo he said a profoundly
misleading set of talking points drafted
by Republican staff attacking the FBI
and its handling of the investigation
this is men only to give Republican
House members a distorted view of the
FBI this may help carry White House
water but it is a deep disservice to our
law-enforcement professionals Adam
Schiff he's saying that you guys are the
ones making it more difficult for law
enforcement at our FBI in our Intel
community to actually operate and I
guess that's for you congressman Stewart
since congressman Duffy is not on the
committee well it's just nonsense and I
had this conversation with mr. Schiff
just a few days ago and let's be clear
about one thing when we talk about DOJ
or FBI
we're not talking about the body we
recognize these are dedicated public
servants we're talking about a few of
the very senior officials within the FBI
and DOJ but the fact you work for the
FBI doesn't mean that no one in that
organization is above question that none
of them are above reproach we have a
responsibility to provide oversight and
when they do something unethical and
potentially illegal that violates the
trust of the American people for
heaven's sakes we have a responsibility
to pursue that you can't say you can't
tell you well you can't attack the FBI
you can't attack DOJ that's just
silliness and by the way when he refers
to us we're protecting mr. Trump that's
the thing that I reacted most
emotionally it's just simply not true
it's just an aversion from the act that
we've seen things here that trouble us
all right well congressman Duffy before
we let you both go it asked a very
simple question
rod Rosenstein is the Deputy Attorney
General he was named Deputy Attorney
General by jeff Sessions Jeff Sessions
recuse himself from the Ruston Russia
investigation Rosenstein he's the man in
the hot seat he's playing hot potato but
this whole thing he's like I'm not doing
it I'm gonna do a special counsel this
is idiotic idiotic idea on his part
sorry but it was and my sources are
telling me that he is vulnerable in this
report and given what we learned about
an extension of a FISA warrant can you
tell us anything about that congressman
Duffy III can't make a comment on that
by the way what I can say is Rosenstein
has been not cooperative he's won who's
helped Stonewall the Congress it took us
four months to get these documents so I
think if you want to clear the FBI if
you want to clear the DOJ be transparent
show us all the elation that might have
yeah well but but but even beyond that
there's not information and and if we're
gonna if we're gonna bully investigate
what they've done at the DOJ and the FBI
we need we need fair partners to work
with us and I don't think Rosenstein has
been that for a partner well if he's not
giving you the information the question
is why if national security isn't
implicated why can't the people get this
information out there then clear the air
if everything's behind everything's
copacetic it's fine you you will get the
memo you're gonna you're gonna see it I
think the Intel committee will vote on
it and you'll have a chance to see it in
Sochi will America
not to know or itching for the hashtag
you know release them release the report
is still trending on release the memo
still trending on Twitter now we have to
have other Schumer shut down trend as
well oh the ship no we're already doing
that come on give me some credit here
Duffy alright guys well I'm sorry do you
have to queue stay up late at night but
you know just give another cup of
espresso do something to keep yourselves
out